人狼ゲーム100人でやったらどうなるの
こんにちははじめしゃちょーですはい皆様
は人狼ゲームというものをご存知でしょう
か人狼ゲームとは人狼ゲームという言葉を
聞いたことある人たくさんいると思うん
ですけどもどんなゲームかっていうの
あんまりよくわかんないよって人のために
説明します人狼ゲームとは人狼側と村人側
で分かれ戦うゲームです人狼ゲームの
あらすじとある平和な村に人の見た目をし
た
狼これを人狼と呼びます
狼が紛れ込んでいます人狼は夜になると
村人の誰が一人を食い殺してしまいます
昼間は村人が全員起きているのでさすがの
人狼も大人数は勝てないため大人しくして
います
村人たちはこの
昼間の時間で
村に紛れ込んだ人狼を探し出して
処刑をしなければなりませんですが人狼は
人の見た目をしているので誰が人狼か
村人にはわからない
村には村人と人狼以外に人狼かどうかを
見分ける能力を持った
占
昼間に処刑された人が人狼だったか人狼
じゃなかったかがわかる
霊能力者など
特徴を持った人がいます
村人たちは彼らの話す情報をもとに誰が
人狼かを暴き出して
村から人狼を排除するために
毎日一人ずつ処刑しなければいけません
人狼に村人が殺され続けて
村が全滅してしまうのが先か人狼を処刑し
て平和が訪れるのが先か
村人たちの生存をかけた戦いが今始まり
ますていうのが人狼ゲームですね基本的に
は56人とかで遊ぶのかなそれぐらいの
人数でキャッキャやるんですけども今回
それを100人でやってみました
したですすいません
100人人狼ゲーム実際やったのが実は
去年の秋ぐらいですね去年の秋にあったん
ですけどももう
編集がきつすぎて編集きつすぎて出すのに
めっちゃ時間がかかってしまったすいませ
ん情報量が多すぎて村人100人もいると
本当にすごいことになったんでぜひ皆さん
は今回そんな100人人狼の世界をお
楽しみくださいそもそも人狼が勝つのが
村人が勝つのかかなり気になると思います
まあ人狼ゲームは簡単に言うとお昼に村人
たちで話し合って誰が人狼なのかをこう
話し合ってその人を処刑します夜は人狼側
で人に決めて
村人を襲撃して殺しますと人狼側は村人と
人狼の数が同じになったら勝利それはもう
出るのが強いからね村人より多かったら
勝ちですよ村人側は人狼を絶滅させられれ
ば勝ちというゲームになってます役職って
いうのもあって人狼村人のほかにさっきも
言ったんですけども村人の中には占い師
っていうあの人が人狼かどうか占いの人
だったり
騎士っていう人狼に村人が襲われるのは
助ける人がいたりそして霊能力者霊媒師
村人たちで話し合って処刑した人が人狼
だったのか人間だったのかわかる人がい
ます
果たしてどうなってしまうのか100人中
の世界ご覧くださいどうぞ
[音楽]
いやー隣にイケメンだと緊張しちゃうな
隣でハンサムだと緊張するな油圧変えて
くる
が始まろうとしております100人中
村人が50人占い師が7人霊能者が7人
騎士が7人
神が1人
間違いなく先に殺されるよ人柄でゲーム
左右する人間だと思うんでちょっと僕は
省かせてというか今回神でやらせて
いただきます先に殺されるだろうし
殺されなくても逆に不自然だし人狼が28
人元々の占い師で7人に人狼の28人が私
にも占い師ですって言ったら占い師35人
になるんですよちょっと本当にどうなるか
わかんないですしちゃんとゲームが進行
するかも分かりませんけど果たして勝つの
はどっちなのかそしていつ終わるのか
スタジオの借りてる時間も決まっており
ます制限時間内に無事終了できるのか
頑張っていきたいと思います
皆さんお待たせいたしました100人人狼
ゲームスタートです
今から皆さんにはカードを1枚ずつお配り
します1枚撮ったやつ隣の方に回して
ください
[音楽]
皆さん見せないように気をつけてください
腕を捨てて目を閉じてくださいそれでは
人狼の方は目を伏せたまま
ゆっくりと手を上げてください人狼の方は
目を振ってたまま
ゆっくりと
仲間を確認してください今手を上げている
方が人狼の仲間同士です
占い師Aの方は手を挙げください本日
占いに対しての番号を受け入れマスターに
お伝えください
占い師Bの方は
ゆっくりと教えたまま手を挙げてください
岸Aの方は目を打てたままゆっくりと手を
上げてください
医師Aの方は目を伏せたままゆっくりと手
を挙げてください
岸Bの方は美容してたものはゆっくりと手
霊能者Aの方は目を捨てたままゆっくりと
手を見てください
霊能者Bの方Bの方Bの方Bの方FのかG
の方は
[音楽]
皆さん顔を上げてください
それでは初日の
義務を初日の議論時間を数えます
お前
怪しいぞ
みんなを見てください
[音楽]
僕は村人です
議論の時間がありますので今皆さん疑心
暗鬼になっていることだと思います誰かの
誰かでしょうかわからない1回落ち着いて
席にしておりましょう
問題はこの人数思って何を話せばいい
じゃんというわけで1日目です皆さん
こんにちは神です
あまりないのでまずは占い師から聞いた方
がいいですかね占い師の人いますか
[音楽]
占い師の人
占いした人一番
怪しいの出てきたぞ
怪しい
んですかちょっと隠れてみようかなと思い
ました
怪しい他にいます一応7
人いるはずです
じゃあ記事の皆さん皆さんは
占い師に手をあげたり
次は守ってもらえると助かります僕
占いの結果72番さん人狼です
信じられない
嘘つきがいる86番が人狼です
[拍手]
初見したい人を指差しで投票します神以外
の人は指を上げてください
[音楽]
投票です
ね
番号後半の人たちに狙われててだからこれ
ちょっと多数決で俺を決めたいので神とし
てはこっちの方が
分かりました決めましたそれでは
処刑する人を発表していただきます
どうして僕を指定するんですか
をしていますでしょうか
[音楽]
ありませんこんな
村にはいられません
処刑された人は以後幽霊になりゲームに
参加することができません
[音楽]
手を上げてください
人狼は顔を上げて起きてください
[音楽]
人狼の皆さんにお伝えします
朝が来ました
皆さん顔を上げてください
本日人狼によって無残な主体で見つかった
人は一番です一番の方は2個ゲームには
参加できません
それでは2日目の議論を始めますどうぞ
はい皆さん2日目です記事でも占い師でも
簡単に名乗り出ると殺されるリスクがある
ので難しいと思うんですけれども何か言い
たいことがあるからぜひ84番さんお願い
します私は霊能者です霊能者86番なんと
なんと人狼でした
[拍手]
裏返したと思います
なるほどなるほど皆さんいろんな意見が
あると思いますがいろいろ考えながら聞い
てみてください初日
占い結果言ったところはあるんですけど
占い師の方名乗り出れる方いますか
占い師です
ね
94番さん人狼です
あ間違えました49番さん
あるんですか
ちなみに好きなタイプはこの中で
は
[音楽]
占い師を狭めるために
霊能者は全員出るべきだと思っております
その上で実は僕怪しい人を人物を3人ほど
見つけてなので
霊能者が出たタイミングで僕に発言をもう
一度いただければと思っておりますわかり
ましたとりあえずじゃあ霊能者さん聞いて
まいります
弁護士さん他にいらっしゃいますか85番
さん最後の留意コン通りちょっと見てみた
んですが白であってます85番さんは村人
初日は
隣のだったんですが
なるほどなるほど先ほど
言っているので91番さんが今のこの夜に
誰を占ったかで確実にその方は白ってのが
わかるかなと思うので91番の知りたい
ですわかりましたまだ情報量多くね忙しい
ね
神だと
信仰してきた村人なのでちょっと疑われる
の
いますか
議論時間終了です本日
処刑したい人を一斉投票します
[音楽]
それでは神は処刑する人を決めてください
結構
矢印の方向が
かなり集中してますね非常に神に信仰心を
持ってくださってるのはありがたいんです
か
村で決まったことです
36番です
結婚してください
[音楽]
[拍手]
1時間経過しました2日目の夜です
[音楽]
朝になりました皆さん目を覚まして
ください本日49番の中でが人狼によって
ビザの主体でありました
お前のせいだ
の議論を開始しますはい皆さんおはよう
ございます行ってみましょうかはいどうぞ
今人道だけが人狼が誰かわかってる状況で
今市民が村人側がすごい不利なんですよね
霊能者とか占い師とかは一気に制度で誰を
占ったか言うとかその霊能者も結果を
例えば人狼とか市民とかせーので出すと
ちょっとボールが出てきて分かりやすく
なるのかなというのと昨日ですね東京の時
にさんが最初は人狼を見つけられたんです
けど違う人も指さされてたんで
あれっていうのはありました
最初の日は僕を指差してたんですけど次の
日36番さんさて6番さん
指さしてたんですねそういうところを見て
たんですけど何て言うんでしょう
[音楽]
何て言ったらいいですか
一緒に
1個だけいいですか73番さん人狼です
よね行きましょうかじゃマイク渡しとき
ます
[音楽]
人狼でした黒です
霊能力者ですね
どれくらいいますか
占い師の方前に来てもらっていいですか
さっき手上げてなかったんですけど実は
占い師で1回目に一番
占って白で2回目発言したかったんです
けど時間なくできなくて30番さんが人狼
でした
すいませんまずいです67番さんこの人狼
です
避難時間終了です
それでは本日
処刑したい人を投票していただきます
それでは紙を処刑する人を決めてください
にも多いけど山中だなぁ
[音楽]
なんか君のことがみんなバカかよ
ギャルが来ます
[音楽]
朝になりました朝起きると53番の方が
無残で見つかりました53番の方にゲーム
や参加できません
4日目の議論を始めます皆さんおはよう
ございます20番さんどうしました99番
さんがちょっと前に49番さんがタイプで
見たけど黒だったって言ってたけど49番
さん人狼に食われてなくなったんで人狼が
人狼増えないんで90キロです
あとちょっと確認したいと思うんですけど
霊能力者さんの凸どうだったかになります
聞いてもいいですか
[音楽]
[拍手]
人狼でした市民でしたそしたらもう一人
霊能者の人が出てきてくれれば私とどっち
が嘘ついてるかっていうのがわかると思う
んでそうですね出てきてもらえばいいかな
とはい91番さん
なんですがはい人狼でした
でしょうね
霊能者が出てきてしまうと後半不利になっ
てしまうと思うのでまず今日は99番の人
を釣ってしまって次の日に91番さんは私
がどちらかのこと占ってもらって黒じゃ
なかった本を
霊能士として確定させてもう一人の方を
すればいいと思いますなるほどなるほど
ここであえて霊能者が出るわけにはいか
ないそうですもったいないと僕も一応村人
としての意見を申し上げると英語でしかが
もしどちらか絶対店じゃないですかでここ
に釣られるのが多分9か84番なんで
技師もしいれば全力でどちらか片っぽを
守ってくれれば後半どんどんになるんじゃ
ないかなと思います
芸能の人はもう一人言ってくれないと
皮脂が多分どっちか守るのに
どっちにしようってなっちゃうと思うので
霊能の人にもう一人
意見欲しいですそうですねそれはかなり
する必要もなくなるような気もしますね
先ほどの30番さん
ここで3人目の霊能力者さんが出てきまし
たが
終了です
難しくなってきたな
99番お願いします
夜が来ます
朝になりました
昨晩無残な事態で見つかったのは92番
さんです92番さんは
参加できません
おはようございます
とりあえずじゃあ霊能力者さんに聞いてみ
ましょうか3人連動者さんがいるのでせー
ので聞いてみたいと思います
人狼です
占い師さんに私とケバさんと
頑張ってください」って言ったので
占い師さんの結果っていうのを聞いて
どちらか黒だってばわかるのでその人を
釣ってその次に30番さんが苦労と言った
人を次の日から紹介していくことで人狼の
数減らせるかなと思います確かにでは
占い師さんに聞いてみましょう54番
人間でしたありがとうございます私あの
占い師なんですけど
4072番さん人狼でした
67番嘘をついてる人狼ですまた31番
さん人狼です73番も人狼なんじゃないか
と思うのと9番の方は人狼だと思います
おはようございますここに来て大爆撃的な
占い師が出現しました他にいらっしゃい
ますか初日の黒だった方
占い91番の方でしたっけですよね2日目
の霊能一人しか出てこなかったのはその方
が結果が出たからですよ
ね
おそらく91番の方は本物だと思うんです
よ
占いとして白先を聞きたいんですよ
そうすると9番さんがかなり
怪しいという風になっていますまず
オプション初日出なかったんです
霊能として黒二人ぐらい見えてから出よう
かなと思って初日は特に何も言わずに2日
目に黒2枚目見えたんでここで出ようって
言って出ましたその時91番さん
めちゃくちゃ
信用しててその次に30番のコツさんを
信用したんですよでもその次の日30番
さんつられて黒だったので
議論時間終了です
1歳の
それでは神は処刑する人決めてください
これは
[音楽]
夜が来ます
朝になりました
本日メザンが主体で見つかった人は
誰もいませんでした
騎士の皆さんナイスです
[拍手]
守れるんでしたっけ
守ります
なんか僕的には人に出ちゃってもいいのか
なともはいでも今誰を守ったっていう風に
発言をしてしまうと例えば一番の方を
守ったで今一番大きいし守りました行った
時に人狼が減ってもう1回1番を次殺し
ちゃう可能性があるので下手に名乗り出
ない方がいい気がしますちなみに冷凍緑者
さん聞いてみてもいいですか
先ほどとその前の前の
占いの結果が91番さん以外があんまり
伝わってないので占いの重複とかも避ける
ために
こうやってた方がいいかなって思いました
31は人狼で人間が5番さん20番さん
46は安全です
12番さんが占い師ですね
67を人狼と女性の71番の方は行ったの
にも関わらず今の12番は
607番を今白なので黒と白で今ここが
入れ違っているのですごく怪しいです
占い師の誰かが怪しい感じをしますね人狼
はみんなが目を開けた状態で誰が人狼か手
あげて帰国して決めるんですよね
はいその日誰を襲撃したかもわかりますか
そしたらここで記事が隠れる理由がないと
思うのでなので言います僕自身で
皮脂が守ったのは91番さんでした色違い
終了です
本日
処刑したい人を投票します
[音楽]
67番です
朝になりました朝起きると91番の無残な
死体が見つかりました
7日目の議論を開始します67番の人は
どうでしたか人狼でした
潜伏
占い師さん
6番さん63番
誰かが人狼っぽいなって俺は思ってるん
ですよなんかさっき噛み合ってなかったん
で私は73
多すぎてやばい頭に覚えておいてください
67番さん両方にしろを投げてるんですよ
そこの色は違えてる色結果なので12番
さん両方に白を投げてる時点で12番さん
何か弁明の余地はありますでしょうか
なんか考えてたらしいですねただごめん
なさい僕本物の
占い師です15番さんになりました
だいぶ発言多いので
占いしてみたら黒です黒です間違いあり
ません黒ですこの方この方を今日釣る時
です
議論時間終了です
投票します
処刑したい人を指示させてください
ひび割れてください1せーのそれでは神は
処刑する人を決めてくださいなるほど
[音楽]
12番さんで
こんにちは神ですここからはちょっと動画
か以上に長すぎるので僕がダイジェストに
お伝えしていきたいと思いますこんなに
長くなると思ってなかったです初日はまあ
なかなか
議論がまとまらず一人目が処刑されて
しまいます
初めてだからとか100人で人狼ゲームし
たことある人いないと思うのでかなり大
混乱パニック状態でした2日目以降から
次々と役職持ちの村人が登場して
議論がかなり難航しました
占い師だけで何人いるんだと
霊媒者も何人いるんだともう本当に
めちゃくちゃでしたねハチャメチャな状態
になってしまいましたそして4日目には
事件が発生しました
霊能者同士で
意見の食い違いが起こってしまって人狼が
どっちかが人狼じゃないかと人狼が紛れて
いるんじゃないかということが発覚します
その後議論が加速し新たな霊能者が現れ9
番の
霊能者が人狼であると指摘され
処刑されました6日目に突入で積極的に
発言をしていた17番の方がなんと自分が
騎士であると
告白しましたそして昨晩91番
占い師が狙われたと証言その後はあんまり
大きな進展がなく91番と71番の占い師
が人狼によって
殺されてしまいます記事であることを告白
するのもかなりリスクがあるというかこう
人狼側からすると
狙われやすくなるのでなかなか発言が
難しそうでしたね11日目には新たに89
番の方が占い師として名乗り出てくれまし
た12日目に
積極的に話していたついのお隣の方15番
さんが
疑惑をかけられてしまい身の潔白を証明
するために
騎士であると自分の約束を告白しました
ですが17番の記事によって人狼であると
見破られてしまい
処刑されてしまいます
けど15番さんは私は89を選んだんです
けれども実は89枚選んでたんですなんで
昨日89番の選べないはずな
処刑されにくくなるのでまあでもこれも何
が本当なのか俺はよくわかんなかったです
もう神も全く意味が分かりませんここまで
いかがだったでしょうか総勢なんと24人
の村人が犠牲になり残った村人は76人
ですさあこの先ゲームはどうなっていくの
でしょうかてかいつ帰れるのでしょうか
みんなイライラしないかな手伝ってくれた
皆様ありがとうございます
[音楽]
すごい意味わからないことが起きてて
さっき54番さん守ったじゃないですか
はいその後僕行ったと思うんですけど誰か
当たったら次はばらけさせようって言った
じゃないですかでばらけさせて僕は洋平
先生
に5番が選ばれて票がバラけたのかなって
思ったらなぜか洋平先生が襲撃されて
みたいなよく
助かりました
ここで出会うとしたら54番が可能性高く
て次に3番さんかなと思っんですけどなん
で5番が狙われたのかっていうのが
ちょっと意味不明です
かね
実は54番
守った時僕54番にかけてなかったんです
よでも54番になったということは他に父
が残っているということになると思います
45番さんお願いしますちょっと質問なん
ですけど89番さんさっき15番さんの
こと占って白って言っ
たんですよ
ね
75番さん役職の情報を含め結構人少ない
と本当にさっき45番さん誰かが言った
通り役職本当に使用してもらわないと議論
も進まないし誰ももっといいかわかんない
状態でどんどんと言われるんですこの状況
一番よくないんじゃないかなと思います
[音楽]
イケメンになってるふざけんこれ朝起きる
と5番が死体で見つかりました
どうも神です何から始めればいいですか
88番
村人なんですけど情報整理したいと思い
ます
探偵で占い師って名乗り出てる人からの
貰ってる白酒が16番さんと20番さんと
25番さんと37番さんと43番さんと
46番さんと97番さんは確定で村人です
ありがとうございます
よくわかんないじゃあ人狼は誰です
89番さん
69番さん
番の人って変わってた気がするので
仲間じゃないかなと思いますじゃあそうし
ます
僕じゃなくて1年後は
隣の人でございました
ので25番さんが
満面的に飲む可能性があるよねとは思い
ます本当に普通の村人なのでちょっと
困ってますちょっとどうしたらいいか
わからないんですけど本当に村人です
可愛いから
信じます75番さんを僕は今怪しいと思っ
ておりまして15番さん
吊られてプロだったんですけど45番さん
が
怪しいですって言った時にもいや45番
さんの方がおかしいんじゃないですか
みたいな発言だったりとか15番さん吊ら
れる直前騎士です」って言った時に17番
さんの方に
矛先を向けるような動きっていうものを見
たので
15番最新じゃないかなと思っております
なるほど
可愛いので信じます
形は実際事実ではあるんですけど誰が真に
なるか本当にわかんない状態で村人が適当
にかましただけなんで
一斉の
おっとこれは話から推測するんだどれに
しよう
56番一番意見出してて生地を守って
占い師の先をテープを教えて黒くゴロゴロ
してきた僕が怪しいって言ってた68番
さんはごめんなさいつってほしいです
さすがに人間ではないと思います
[音楽]
うわイケメンタイム終わった最悪
17番
とうとう村の
英雄と称えられた17番の騎士さんが人狼
によって食われてしまいます自分で役職を
言ってしまったので仕方ないですねよく
ここまで頑張ってくれましたここで83番
さんが自分が
霊能者であると名乗り出てくれました83
番が言うにはいきなり
傭兵くんが狙われたことが怪しかったよう
でもしかすると畑メンバーにも人狼が潜ん
でいる可能性があるんじゃないかと言って
いましたでもねなんかエンタメ要素で
面白いと思って
殺されてしまった可能性もありますよね
この日は75万さんが処刑されてしまい
ましたその後議論は進展せず3番さん
疑われていた85番さん54番のお天気
お姉さん22番さんが処刑
追放されてしまいましたはいというわけで
19日目の夜です時間が5時間を経過し
ました人数が72を切ったということで
だいぶ減りましたねちょっと待ってどれ
だけ人狼も残ってるかあと役職の人がどれ
わかんないんでまだ読めないです20日目
以降からは
霊能者が2人に増え話を進めて
くれたがどんどん狙われて
転
んで本格的に
議論を潰しに来たように感じました
めっちゃね主要人物がね殺されていた
そして21日目からはあまり議論が進まず
人狼によって33番さんが殺されてしまい
ますここからは死の時間か
占い師が殺されて以降情報がなくなっ
ちゃうんですよ議論が進展せず次々と
処刑されていってしまいますどうなって
しまうのでしょうか
人殺したらやだな
もう人殺したくねぇよ
と思うんですよ
人が死んだ時に頷くのはいかにも人間の力
のコード
さんは人間でした
だんだんかわいそうになってきました
死んでもらいます
またまた人間でした
[音楽]
おはようございますもう役職持ってる人は
いないような気もしてます
人殺しだみんなが決めたんだろう
疑われてるんでやっぱり疑われてる人やっ
ちゃった方がいいんじゃないですか
出てきて多分また殺されちゃうとあれなん
でカミングアウトするんですけど私
岸です
タイミングかっこよせーの
[音楽]
時計です
30日目ですとなっていたのは61番です
この村に新郎が来て1ヶ月が経ちました
怖いでしょこんな早く終わらせましょう
霊能者が2人出たので
どうでした
[音楽]
なるほどそれでは決めてください10番
初見でお願いしますチャンネル登録と高
評価よろしくお願い致します
[音楽]
先ほど10番が役職を切って間違えた時に
隣の18番の方が山ってギリギリ超える
ぐらいの
言ってしまったおそらく
ないです
せーの
18番さん初見です
[音楽]
神様頑張って
に聞いてみましょう先ほどのテリーさんが
殺した女の子は
人狼でした
すごいちょっと周りの方もさっと見た一言
とかで
意外と気付けると思うのでちょっと見せて
ください
痛くなかったんですけど教室ずっと数時間
隣で
仲良くしてもらって
信じてたんですけど18を察してなかった
んですね19番が次
殺されると思うんで19が怪しいかなって
遺言だけ
私今日このお隣のことも
すごい話してて
めっちゃ本当に今日だけでめちゃくちゃ
仲良くなって
なかったんですよ隣に残っておっしゃって
私出していいかわからなくてその97番
さんがあちらの方と連携とっててなんか
手首になるのかなと思って私もやって97
番さんに入れたんですよになってるから
わかりませんが私は市民です
82番さんと話してたんですけど19番
さんがその18番さんとすごい仲良くは
かかるんですけどタクシーの97番さんを
指すのはなんかおかしいんじゃないかなっ
てちょっと思いました本当に私がバカ
すぎるのがいけないんですけど全然内容
理解できてなくてそしてって言われた時も
こっち行ったりこっち行ったりするぐらい
有名になってないんですけど
めっちゃ適当に出しましたすいません
貯金したい人を指さしていただきます
19番さん
処刑です
7時間経過しました
33日目残り44人で7時間経過しました
結構みんなも疲れてきてますしもう夜中
ですそして勝負がマジでわかんなくなって
きてます
[音楽]
頑張ります
さあデイ33も1ヶ月以上
殺しが続いてます33日目で7時間が経過
してなんと死者
66人になりました
もうね俺の記憶だとかなり精神的に疲れて
ましたね皆さん情報量が多すぎて
何が何だかわかんないんですけども
ただただ
霊能者とか役職ある人が出てこないか誰か
ヒントをくれても出てきたら人狼に殺され
ちゃうっていうすごい葛藤がありましたね
ジレンマですもうこれは
その後
議論が進まないまま役職持ちがどんどんと
殺されていってしまい俺もね神もやっぱ
こんだけ村人が殺されるとストレスで結構
暴飲暴食しちゃったよねちょっと太ったか
な俺ちょっと太っちゃいましたこれきっと
[音楽]
え
っ食べ過ぎた食べ過ぎだろ
よろしくお願いします見つかった人は82
番です飛行ゲームから脱落します
はい41日目ということで
治療核じゃない方は立ってみてください
収穫です個人的に
70万76は788だからお話をお聞きし
たいです70番です
村人です役職がなかったのであまり発言は
控えてたんですけど
村人が続いて76番とかないのでこう
手ぶらでメモを取ったりとかもしてないの
で白確でない方でも
捉えてる方はもしかしたら
昇格の人を釣り台狙うみたいにやってるの
かなとちょっと疑念を持っております役職
なしの村人で本当にこれ以上言うことが
ないのでただここでいろいろしゃべっても
なんか変に転がれって言ったからね
[音楽]
静かに座ってましたはいありがとうござい
ますどうですか
78番怪しいな
はい発表してください
[音楽]
47番の方
によって
26ダイエット
成功おはようございます
疑いのある人たちましょう95番
何も約束なくて何もしてなくてたんです
けど役職ない
村人だからこそメモを取らないといけない
んじゃないかなるほど
現状に
人狼または怠惰な村人だと可能性が出てき
ましたけれども役職がない人ほどメモし
たり
[音楽]
怠惰な村人の処刑後は
村人は人狼の目星がつかずかなり
混乱状態になってしまいました
議論中も情報がないまま次々と追放そして
処刑されていきますこれ俺の勝手な憶測に
なっちゃうんですけども今思えば後半
生き残ってた人狼ってこれが狙いだったの
かなとも思いますねもうどうしようもない
状況
絶望的な状況にさして
混乱しちゃって議論を完全に止めよう
みたいな感じでさあこの後の続きも見て
いきましょういつ終わるのでしょうか
見つかった人は23番です
立ってくださいこの中にいることは間違い
ないんですそして59番は帽子をかぶって
いる
と思いますそうですね
なったんですけど白学の52番さんと37
番さんこっち側をさせてたんです
何か理由があればお聞きしたいです
か
[音楽]
見つかった人は25%
ございます
27番さん騎士だったみたいです役職の方
もいないですよねあそこまで隠してる人が
いるとなんかまだいそうだなって思っ
ちゃいますけど逆に隠してて最後大学生と
かされると嬉しいですけど今みたいに殺さ
れちゃう可能性もあるのでそこは判断任せ
たいです今1周白確じゃない人のお話聞い
てみたんですけども改めて
[音楽]
になったと思うんですけどもその時に24
番さん来て自分の番号確認してて注意して
まさか自分が的な白
っぽいような気がしました
[音楽]
59番初見です
違うよ
[音楽]
4人だけかここの線は薄いという考えで
行ってもいいんでしょうかね逆に座ってる
人から燃やしていきますよ1人ずつどう
ですか今のところ怪しいと思った行動とか
ありますか
議論時間終了です
おはようございます
さっき僕なぜ70倍になったかというと
自分刺してたんですよこのタイミングで
自分させて多分次の時のアリバイ作りに
見えたんでなんか安全に人狼じゃない疑い
をかけられないようなムーブかなと思って
怪しいので早めに
燃やしときました数学の人買ってください
さっきの話の続き87番さんが人を指さし
だってお聞きしたんですけども本当に刺し
てたのかそしてその意図をお聞きできると
嬉しいです
貯金がどんどんみんななくて37番さんは
ニコニコしてこの状況を楽しんでいるのか
なと思ってなんかそこで相手を37番を
指して私は
あっていうことで
表記の殺人鬼ということです
ニコニコしてこの状況を見られてるという
ことですね
おはようございます
残り10人となりました俺はまだ村人
勝てるチャンスあると思ってますマジの
確率論で言うとそこなんです
確率の話で言いますと他にヒントがなけれ
ばそういう確率だろう
唯一行動として挙げられるのが55番さん
の
途中でスマホを出してメモを取ってると
いう動作がやっぱり
[音楽]
です
[拍手]
この時点で勝利した事例があります
人狼は全ていなくなりぐらい
[音楽]
[拍手]
皆さんお疲れ様でした
皆さん最終的に残り9人そして50日目で
かかった時間8時間47分でした
[拍手]
[音楽]
お疲れ様でした